the central focus of whatever small
amount of mental training I give my
students comes down to a very very
simple concept to understand this is the
idea of
identifying competition in terms of its
normalcy
most people see training and competition
is two different things training is
normal activity that you do every day
and competition is the exception okay
it's different you're going out there's
people watching you there's a big crowd
they're making lots of noise
um
in fact
the promoters of shows go out of their
way to reinforce this
look at for example ADCC when Gordon
Ryan went to fight Andre Galvan okay do
they just come out on the mat and fight
each other absolutely not this music
there's a pageantry there's Fireballs
they're literally shooting Fireballs
yeah some dude in a tie sitting with Joe
Rogan Meathead uh podcaster comedian
whatever uh which one was the meat head
what well played John Idaho well played
but you see what they're trying to do
they're trying to create theater and
pageantry when in fact it's just a
grappling match it's just two athletes a
referee and a rule set that's that's the
reality
now what they try to sell you is
something which is not reality which is
this is somehow bigger and different
and they reinforce this with pageantry
and theater so that it becomes not just
a grappling match but a grappling
performance the same way you have a
theater performance
and my goal as a coach is to dispel that
and say when you go out there
there's only one reality
you him and the referee reinforcing a
rule set that's it everything else you
see the smoke the fire the music is an
illusion
and it's put there intentionally to make
you feel a certain kind of way and your
whole goal is to see this as an illusion
and walk out and see only the reality
which is that this is the same damn
thing you do every day in the gym
the only difference is you're going with
a guy you've never grabbed before
so the actual act of removing the
illusion or realizing that it is an
illusion
how do you practice that so when you
step on the mat once you're aware of it
I I always have them to you it it's like
when you when you see a magician and you
have his tricks explained to you
you never see the magic again the first
time you see a good card trick from a
good magician's oh my God then when they
explain it to you I did this this and
that step one step two
then you look at it like it's not that
special
and when you explain to people this idea
of the pageantry is an illusion
then just as when you watch the magician
and you learn the trick
all the magic flies out the window so
too with the the nervous response so
that's for the pageantry but what about
the maybe the physical intensity of
competition isn't there
an extra no it's the same in every
competition it's not like you know
they're twice as strong and 80cc is
there and the ibjf World Championships
it's the physical intensity is always
pretty much the same they experience it
every day in the gym and
um uh like you know if you go out and
you grapple Gordon Ryan it's not like
the next guy who gravel is going to be
twice as strong as hell or twice as fast
these these could be a little stronger a
little faster but not so much so that it
completely changes your approach of the
game
um you know there's not that much
difference between the human bodies out
there on stage so if you've felt
intensity before you're not going to be
shocked by ADCC but in terms of in
training
do you have to try to match the
intensity of competition no
um that would be fool should be every
athlete in the gym would be injured uh
you can do it for short periods of time
um but the uh the training has to be
carefully monitored in terms of
intensity levels remember we're training
seven days a week a minimum of twice a
day
um
you you've got to keep things under
wraps like you know every other workout
you can have a like one of the five
rounds can be full power but not seven
days a week three times a day that's
that's just going to break bodies and
the full power is just a reminder
of it's more about skill development for
us it always comes back to skill
development but what about matching the
the feeling of the intensity of
competition
so yeah periodically periodically it
can't be rare single time not not really
it's not rare like yeah meaning like you
know one like out of you know three
hours of hot sparring per day like 15
minutes might be like 100 full power
that way you you that's more than enough
to get psychologically ready for the
intensity of conflict but um uh but
won't break your body over time
intensity of conflict that's well put
there is a competition does doesn't it
have that extra level of animosity
okay it's a little bit more conflict
than it is that can sometimes his
personality differences like for example
like Gordon Ryan and Felipe Pena they
admire each other a lot they respect
each other's skills but they they
certainly don't like love each other
that's for sure so um uh so there can be
certain match up with this more
intensity
um but then there's other matchups where
the two athletes come out and it's
um it's no more intense than a hard
sparring session